[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue Paris sa clé TV vous
propose une émission spéciale spring 50
un concours un label qui met en avant 50
startups du territoire du cluster Paris
Saclay ce sont les plus innovantes du
moment et elles peuvent donc se faire
connaître et lever des fonds grâce à ce
concours qui est organisé dans le cadre
du Paris Saclay string cette année c'est
à HEC et c'est le premier juin alors ces
startups elles sont accompagnées tout au
long de l'année grâce à des lieux comme
tel Road ou grâce à une plateforme
dédiée et aussi surtout grâce à l'EPA
Paris Saclay vous allez entendre les
explications de Frédéric devèvre il est
chef de projet innovation et
développement économique à l'EPA Paris
Saclay et en attendant de découvrir la
promotion 2023 du Spring 50 focus sur
quatre startups qui ont été
sélectionnées l'année dernière alors
elles sont des projets innovants elle
s'inscrivent dans une démarche
d'économie circulaire elle s'appelle
yesti et Quinoé popcott et kimialiste
enfin notre agenda ce sera la fin de
cette émission et en ce mois de juin il
y a beaucoup beaucoup de choses à faire
on ne va pas s'en plaindre
[Musique]
spring 50 promotion 2023 c'est la
troisième du genre et je vous le disais
l'objectif c'est de les mettre en avant
ces 50 startups du territoire leur
permettent de se faire connaître leur
permettre de lever des fonds pour
grandir et des startups il y en a plus
de 700 sur votre territoire il faut les
accompagner au jour le jour grâce à des
lieux comme celui-ci très grande une
plateforme dédiée et beaucoup d'autres
initiatives menées par le pH Paris
Saclay tout de suite les précisions de
Frédéric devaisre il est chef de projet
innovation et développement économique
[Musique]
au niveau de le plat Paris sacs on
accompagne des entreprises
essentiellement au travers de trois
actions
ces trois actions sont menées en
partenariat étroit avec la french tech
Paris Saclay ça commence par la création
d'un portail qui s'appelle Paris avec
les startups qui a été initié en 2018 ce
portail permet pour les jeunes
entreprises et porteurs de projets
d'accéder en fait un certain nombre de
ressources et notamment toutes les
structures qui peuvent accompagner les
startups dans leur développement c'est à
dire les incubateurs les accélérateurs
les fablabs ça permet aussi de
répertorier toutes les structures qui
peuvent les accueillir ou les héberger
au sein du territoire de Paris Saclay
donc les espèces de coworking les
pépinières d'entreprises et d'autres
structures et bientôt l'offre
d'immobilier Texier le deuxième volet
pour les startups une fois qu'elles sont
constituées c'est tout simplement de les
référencer dans cette plateforme qui est
un annuaire qui rassemble aujourd'hui
plus de 700 startups ça leur permet
d'avoir une visibilité auprès de
différents publics notamment
investisseurs et industriels puisque
ceci dispose également d'un compte sur
la plateforme pour aller un petit peu
sourcer et trouver les sociétés qui les
intéressent le deuxième axe c'est lié
aux recherches de financement puisqu'en
fait on organise une à deux fois par an
des learning expédition investisseurs le
concept en fait c'est d'aller chercher
une trentaine d'investisseurs notamment
fonds à Paris de les amener sur le
territoire notamment dans un lieu
emblématique de la recherche ou de
l'innovation que ce soit privé et public
et à cette occasion on leur présente on
leur fait pitcher 10 start-up dans une
thématique dans un secteur ce qui permet
donc du coup de faire des prises de
contact et puis d'accélérer des levés de
fonds pour les startupers puisque ils
peuvent alors avoir des contacts avec
ces investisseurs et puis le Graal si je
puis dire ou la troisième action majeure
c'est autour de l'événement phare de
l'écosystème qui est Paris avec les
Springs et notamment autour du label
sprint 50 ou au spring fifty que nous
avons créé en 2021
nous au travers de notre label spring 50
on récompense pas la croissance de ces
startups mais plutôt le potentiel c'est
à dire ce sont les pépites de l'année
les entreprises qui ont plus de
potentiels et qui nous sommes
intéressants à présenter parce que c'est
pour elle une année charnière de pouvoir
être mise en lumière au travers de cet
événement de pouvoir pitcher devant un
public d'investisseur d'industriels de
partenaires divers et variés sur les
éditions 2021 et 2022 donc les deux
promotions de sprint 50 on est à plus de
150 millions d'euros levés par ces
startups qui étaient présentes à ces
événements donc on espère que la
sélection les lauréats 2023 auront le
même succès que les deux précédentes
on s'arrête maintenant sur quatre
startups de la promotion 2022 4 startups
labellisées spring 50 elle s'appelle
yestigean et kimialis participer à ce
concours leur a permis de se faire
connaître d'avoir plus de visibilité et
surtout de se développer avec des levées
de fonds qui ont dépassé le million
d'euros alors ces startups elle
participe à l'économie circulaire elle
propose des alternatives aux protéines
animales ou encore aux emballages
plastiques rencontre avec ses jeunes
entrepreneurs en pleine ascension
[Musique]
bonjour à tous je m'appelle Nicolas
stephanovic je suis le président et
co-fondateur de la société
isti
c'est qu'on revalorise un coproduit de
l'industrie brassicole les levures de
brasseries afin d'en faire des
ingrédients sains protéinés et savoureux
à destination d'autres industriels de la
loi alimentaire qui vont pouvoir en
faire plein de produits comme des barres
protéinés des produits nutrition santé
ou même des galettes végétales la
particularité c'est qu'on va récupérer
les levures auprès des brasseurs donc
déjà dans un premier temps on va réduire
leur impact environnemental et réduire
leur coût de traitement ça nous permet
de faire un produit qui est complètement
naturel qui va être sain protéiné et qui
va contenir également défibres des
vitamines et des minéraux tout ça avec
un super
umami qui va porter des notes de viande
ou de fromage dans le produit fini et un
prix compétitif
le projet initier depuis le début lié à
l'Université Paris Saclay notamment
parce que les trois co-fondateurs sont
passés par des écoles de l'écosystème
donc agropariste et centrale Supélec et
qui depuis le départ on travaille donc
en collaration avec agroparité donc ça
soit sur des collaborations techniques
mais aussi sur du financement qui nous a
été apporté par AgroParisTech et par
d'autres entités de l'écosystème
sprint 50 on y a participé pour la
première fois l'année dernière donc avec
deux objectifs rencontrer des potentiels
prospects des potentiels clients pour
initi également auprès des investisseurs
parce qu'on était à ce moment-là en face
de levée de fonds ça a plutôt bien
marché pour les deux donc on est
ressorti de l'événement avec quelques
prospects en plus et également avec nos
toutes premières investisseurs qui a
lancé vraiment la levée de fonds et tu
nous a permis d'aller finaliser ce
premier tour de table pour ce qui est
monté à l'échelle à nos procédés et donc
commencer à vendre en 2024 notre produit
ce qu'on espère pour cette année c'est
renforcer nos liens avec les partenaires
institutionnels qui sont présents là-bas
c'est également potentiellement
rencontrer de nouveaux prospects et de
nouveaux investisseurs qu'on n'a pas vu
l'occasion de voir ou qui n'était pas
présent l'année dernière donc toujours
dans le même objectif
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle hermano Braz je
suis président de la société ekinoa
c'est une start-up qui fabrique de
l'alimentation animale pour les chiens
et les chats à base de protéines
d'insectes évidemment notre fabrication
elle est française les produits de la
gamme ekinoa répondent à deux
problématiques une première c'est
nutritionnelle parce qu'aujourd'hui en
France 40% des chiens et 30% des chats
sont obèses ça c'est le premier point et
il y a un deuxième point c'est qu'il y a
à peu près 600 millions de chiens et
chats sur cette planète et c'est 600
millions de chiens et chats figurez-vous
ils consomment à peu près 20% de la
protéine animale produit de chaque année
avec évidemment des conséquences
environnementales et l'insecte c'est la
vraie solution à ces deux problématiques
la première elle est nutritionnelle
l'insecte c'est aussi riche en protéines
que le bœuf et surtout c'est
naturellement hypoallergénique pour les
chiens les chats les vétérinaires ont
d'ailleurs des spécialités à base
d'insectes dans leur portefeuille de
produits et puis le second c'est
environnemental il faut savoir que pour
produire 1 kg d'insectes versus kg de
bœuf
il faut en moyenne 8 fois moins de
nourriture 10 fois moins de surface 30
fois moins d'eau et surtout ça émet
jusqu'à 300 fois moins de CO2 donc
l'insecte c'est vraiment la protéine de
l'avenir pas seulement pour les chiens
et chats mais aussi pour les humains et
puis un dernier secteur pour
l'aquaculture parce que lorsque on élève
1 kg de truite ou de saumon il faut
savoir que on les nourrit avec 3 kg de
poissons pêchés dans la mer or ces
poissons consomment à l'état naturel des
insectes près de 30% et donc les
aquaculteurs aussi travaillent sur ce
sujet en clair ce que je suis en train
de vous dire c'est que la protéine
d'insectes c'est la protéine du futur
elle est consommée tous les jours par
plus de 2 milliards de personnes qui
sont pas des Néandertaliens ou des
pité-contrope ce sont des gens qui sont
en très bonne santé voilà donc l'insecte
c'est l'avenir de l'homme et c'est
l'avenir d'un animal et bien évidemment
de la planète nous sommes hébergés au
sein de la pépinière oui de Gif sur
Yvette cela nous a permis finalement de
participer et de postuler au spring
Paris-Saclay 2022 et nous avons eu la
chance d'être sélectionné dans la
catégorie food tech aux côtés de 8
autres startups cet événement il a eu
plusieurs impacts sur notre société tout
d'abord il nous a permis de faire
connaître nos produits de faire
connaître le bénéfice des protéines
d'insectes première chose deuxième chose
il nous a permis de rencontrer d'autres
startups et de partager sur nos
problématiques ou nos opportunités et
puis évidemment un dernier point c'est
la rencontre avec différents
investisseurs même si au moment où nous
avons participé au spring Paris Saclay
nous n'étions pas dans cette démarche
nous avons maintenant incarné d'adresses
qui va nous permettre d'enclencher une
levée de fonds sur l'année 2023
[Musique]
chez Emmanuel je suis le fondateur de
pop cut
[Musique]
est-ce que ça vous est arrivé
dernièrement d'acheter de la nourriture
surgelée ou des bonbons et ben vous
l'avez acheté dans un sachet en
plastique aura vous devez savoir que ce
sachet plastique n'est pas recyclable et
ça ne sera pas pendant les prochains 20
ans au moins et qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
ce sécher plastique mais en fait on le
brûle dans le meilleur des cas on brûle
la grande majorité est finie d'un océan
et après amicantes
c'est de se débarrasser de ce plastique
là je vous présente le premier
exemplaire au monde de sachet
d'emballage surgelé complètement à
papier merci à notre technologie qui
transforme le papier dans le plastique
dans ses propriétés de surface dans sa
dans sa capacité d'être bon emballage de
contenir des aliments et mais pas que
tout en gardant les uniques propriétés
de fin de vie du papier donc le papier
reste à 100% recyclable et 100%
biodégradable
on est arrivé à sacré il y a environ un
an pour réinitiative initiative
magnifique de les PEA Paris saclair qui
nous a mis en relation avec la french
tech Paris et Danone qui était plus ou
moins un client c'était quelqu'un avec
des interactions et bien Dana a décidé
d'ouvrir aux portes au startup et nous
on a pu s'installer dans un laboratoire
de 40 m² chez Denon pendant les derniers
six mois et cela nous a permis non
seulement de faire de Danone un vrai
client de vodkot non seulement d'engager
des projets mais aussi d'intégrer
dans sa dans son entièreté l'écosystème
de Paris circulaire et quand je dis en
entière écosystème c'est total c'est
AgroParisTech
c'est toutes les structures qu'on a la
chance d'avoir autour avec leurs experts
leurs scientifiques leur outil leur
machine leur microscope voilà tout ça ça
a permis à pop-corn de faire un bon en
avant
non seulement en commercial avec Danone
mais aussi avec
de la recherche de ce qui est notre cœur
de métier ce qui nous nourrit ce qui
nous nourrit nos produits et nos clients
enfin pas de cote aujourd'hui il y a 2
ans la société compte 5 employés et on
est présent en Chine et à Paris on est
en train d'ouvrir nos opérations aux
États-Unis et pour cela on aidera
bientôt à fond ce qui va être la
première fois au podcast jusque là on
s'est financé uniquement merci à nos
clients et ce qu'on cherche le plus
maintenant j'espère autant des
ressources des financements ça c'est
évidemment bien utile mais ce qui est
clé ce sont des gens des talents
et je suis confiant qu'à Paris on pourra
trouver les bons talents
[Musique]
donc chez kimialis on développe on
produit des traitements chimiques des
surfaces qui sont utilisés pour
développer des tests diagnostics et
d'analyser une vitraux innovant
on est une équipe de 8 personnes
aujourd'hui on est basé à l'ENS Paris
Saclay depuis notre création en octobre
2020 et on commence à avoir des clients
non seulement en Europe mais aussi en
Amérique du Nord et en Asie
les derniers mois ont été l'occasion
tout d'abord de clôturer une première
levée de fond pour qu'il yalisse donc
sécurisé à peu près un million d'euros
pour financer trois pôles importants
d'une part la mise à l'échelle de notre
capacité de production et de traitement
chimique des nanoparticules d'or qui
sont utilisés dans les tests rapides les
tests bandelettes que on a bien utilisé
pendant la pandémie c'est aussi
l'opportunité d'investir dans notre
activité commerciale et marketing sur
lequel on a mis peu d'efforts jusqu'à
présent ce million d'euros va également
servir à poursuivre le co-développement
de trois projets innovants qu'on a
initié avec des partenaires
scientifiques académiques et privés et
qui sont soutenus par des pays France
depuis maintenant presque deux ans je
suis sur la partie d'optimisation et de
donc de développement des tests rapides
en bandelettes donc je fais surtout de
donc des prestations de services pour
les clients pour les aider dans le
développement de leur de leur
bioconjugués donc c'est des
nanoparticules d'or fonctionnalisés avec
des anticorps spécifiques pour détecter
des molécules et aussi donc je travaille
en parallèle sur des projets qu'on a en
interne qui sont toujours liés sur les
tests rapides en bandelette
l'avantage d'être le ns c'est qu'on a
accès à beaucoup de d'instruments et
aussi de personnes qui ont des
connaissances et qui peuvent nous
accompagner sur certains aspects et
aussi pouvoir commencer dans de bonnes
conditions
l'événement sprint Paris Saclay nous a
aidé à mettre la lumière sur kimialise
sur notre levée de fond qui était en
cours à cette époque donc ça nous a aidé
à concrétiser les premières relations
qu'on avait avec des investisseurs à ce
moment-là depuis l'événement spring on a
également été certifié ISO 9000 ans 2015
qui est une première étape dans le dans
notre trajectoire industrielle c'est
vrai que l'événement spring a mis cette
lumière dont on a besoin pour accélérer
jusqu'à la levée d'amorçage et enchaîner
[Musique]
notre agenda présent le moment le
rendez-vous à ne pas manquer bien sûr
c'est paris-saclet spring c'est le 1er
juin à HEC Paris à 9 heures et le
lendemain pour les inscrire au circuit
de l'innovation il est toujours le temps
de s'inscrire qui seront les lauréats du
Prix du livre scientifique 2023 pour le
savoir rendez-vous le 3 juin au Théâtre
de la passerelle c'est à Palaiseau au
programme un après-midi autour des
livres et des sciences avec des ateliers
destinés aux enfants ainsi qu'un
spectacle tout public magie Cosmo
logique mardi 6 juin vous avez
rendez-vous à la librairie La Girafe
c'est dans le quartier de Moulon à
partir de 18h30 rencontre autour du
livre Paris Saclay l'aménagement d'un
territoire d'économie du savoir écrit
par Jean-Philippe Hugron séparé aux
éditions archi books et c'est en
présence de Benoît Lebeau le directeur
de l'aménagement à le PA Paris Saclay on
vous en parle souvent dans cette
émission le 7 juin 17h30 inauguration du
pavillon réciproque ces PLA à Palaiseau
dans le quartier de l'École
polytechnique et on a aussi beaucoup
évoqué les startups dans cette émission
spéciale spring 50 et bien sachez que 50
ans en Yvelines lance un nouvel appel à
candidature pour intégrer l'incubateur
ce qui cube les porteurs de projets
d'innovation technologiques ou de
services les dirigeants de start-up en
face de croissance peuvent candidater
jusqu'au mardi 20 juin une réunion
d'information est organisée le jeudi 8
juin à skikub allez on n'oublie pas les
sportifs avec les Olympiades de Paris
Saclay un week-end sportif et festif
pour toute la famille les 10 et 11 juin
rendez-vous sur le plateau de Moulon
pour un tout nouvel événement organisé
par l'agglomération un week-end en plein
air où il fera bon chez ses baskets ou
prendre son vélo ou les deux et enfin si
vous aimez le théâtre si vous aimez
Molière Versailles célèbre la 27e
édition du Mois Molière c'est un mois de
théâtre et de danse dans 60 lieux
différents alors pour tout savoir un
seul site
moi molière.com et voilà c'est déjà la
fin de cette émission spéciale spring 50
on a hâte de vous retrouver pour vous
dévoiler le palmarès pour vous dévoiler
les 50 startups retenues dans le cadre
de Spring 50 revenir aussi sur cette
nouvelle édition du Paris-Saclay spring
à très bientôt
[Musique]